welcome back to many of you who were
here last week for the first William
Fulks Stimson lectures under the general
title America confronts the
post-imperial world
William Faulk is a remarkable individual
a veteran foreign policy consultant
author and professor of Middle Eastern
Studies President Kennedy appointed him
to the State Department's policy
planning committee where he served
during the Cuban Missile Crisis as I I
think I said last week I thought if
there's anybody else in the world
writing books in 2018 who was in the
Kennedy administration I don't know that
it is and he's written a great many
books just some of them violent politics
insurgency and terrorism neighbors and
strangers the fundamentals of foreign
affairs understanding Iraq understanding
Iran distant thunder reflections on the
dangers of our times and humpty-dumpty
not to mention the fate of regime change
I think what's quite remarkable about
William Faulk in addition to his
amazingly prolific Peg's is that he's
he's somebody who really has throughout
his career straddled the world of real
politics and the university he started a
major Middle East sentence
particularly important one at the
University of Chicago he was a professor
at Harvard before he went into politics
and has always had one foot in the
Academy and he should he stands
therefore as an example to to us his his
last lecture was Snow White's mirror
what we see and what others see that it
was about for those of you who were not
here how Americans self perceptions
stand in some considerable tension with
the way others perceive them in the
world and he traced this all the way
back to the war of independence and all
the way forward to our time today he's
going to be talking about how from our
earliest days we've been set by fear of
violence and have increasingly put off a
[Applause]
it's a great pleasure to be here and a
particular pleasure to see that some of
you came back again in my first talk I
discussed the role of colonialism and
the fascination of with war that
Americans expressed in thought and
action I now want to turn back the clock
to the Constitutional Convention of 1787
to discuss how from our earliest days
we've been excited by and also
frightened by the ability the military
as an institution and the military is a
mindset to engage us in war I will go
into detail on these issues because I
believe they're the most important
touchstones we have to evaluate our
current problems and potentials and
because it appears to me that so few
Americans know much about our social
contract the Constitution to judge the
legality of our actions and to uphold
the essential principles that we have
jurists of whom I'm not one today often
act as historian of whom I am one like
historians the lawyers and judges go
back to the authors and events that
shaped the Constitution but it's
surprising how few of our contemporaries
do this is not an arcane activity the
laws of affect our daily lives are
matched or should be matched against
constitutional standards yet as the
prominent historian of America Gordon
wood
has written most universities have long
since given up teaching undergraduate
courses in American constitutional
history and most of those few remaining
professors who do teach it are retiring
and not being replaced a poll conducted
a few years ago found that more than one
in three Americans did not know and what
century the American Revolution happened
and probably even fewer could have said
what the when the Constitution was
written or what it mandated so I ask
your indulgence if I repeat what you
already know I will be delighted and if
I supply new information or insights
perhaps you may find that helpful
I find it fruitful to think of the
Constitution I was teased by saying that
the other day I spoke to you about so
much mirrored I am going to talk to you
about a tree I like to think of the
Constitution as a tree then we can ask
when it was planted what the soil its
roots had to find their way into how its
trunk and branches took shape at the
1787 Constitutional Convention and how
successive judges and political leaders
have grafted new branches onto it so
that it shapes the America we have today
I'll take up first the soil in which the
Constitution tree was planted what
brought the men who gathered in
Philadelphia and the uncomfortable
Statehouse during the hot and humid
summer of 1787 failure during the
Revolutionary War it came to when it
came to national interests General
George Washington found that even in the
midst of battle militia troops that is
the people under arms had the habit of
just running away occasionally without
even firing their weapons Washington
regarded them as simple cannon fodder
cannon fodder and despite hours pride in
the spirit of 1776 that spirit is more
evident in retrospect than it was that
as the chief engineer of the Continental
Army
the French volunteer Louis de puta
lamented there are a hundred times more
enthusiasm in any Paris cafe for the
American Revolution then I find in all
the colonies put together many American
colonists have focused on their private
aims at that time sold food and
equipment to the British and starved
Washington at Valley Forge others found
it more profitable and safer to kill
Indians than to fight the British this
is not surprising we see the same
shortfalls today among formerly colonial
peoples throughout Asia and Africa
making the transition from colonialism
which I talked about so much last time
to independence is a very slow process
and during the time it takes to create
the sort of national esprit de corps the
transition requires there are many many
setbacks we see these failures
disillusionment sand bouts of
lawlessness glaringly in our daily
newspapers in the shale shaky regimes
and so-called failed States and much of
the world often the newly liberated
people to come to feel nostalgia for
their former regimes as they look around
themselves they see that former colonial
auxiliaries who frequently become
oppressive armies and former freedom
fighters have become tyrants or warlords
post-revolutionary America hovered on
the brink of the similar anarchy true
the colonists had won the war of the
revolution but in the peace that
followed America was what we would call
today a failed state the first attempt
at forming the new country had not
worked the people had seen that their
sacrifices had not brought the
millennium they had hoped for the mood
of the American public as reported
throughout the former colonies was one
of confusion dejection and anarchy
everyone was distressed some even
advocated returning to the British
Empire
as the yellow press would let her coin
the phrase the public was seething the
governing institution the continent the
confederation conference Congress the
successor to the Continental Congress
had not taken it could not cope with the
strong will that independence of the
several states it could not ensure
domestic tranquility the favorite phrase
of course in the subsequent Constitution
nor any more than British could to
prevent the rest of scholars from
provoking war with the Indian nations on
the frontier in short Americans were
suffering with what I've called in
describing societies today in Africa and
Asia
post-colonial malaise the more
established that is the earlier
immigrants who'd been running the
colonies realized that they must do
something to bring a sense of order
that's why they were gathering to plant
a new tree what apparently they did to
share sorry I beg your pardon what about
the soil in which they were trusting
trusting their spades
it would have been almost unimaginable
to young Americans today in the context
of 1787 and except for dress and
language the delegates would have looked
and not felt out of place in Calcutta
Legos Mogadishu or the capital of any
African or Asian failed state the
streets of Philadelphia were open sewers
with swarms of mosquitoes flaws feeding
on the faces of animals and humans
crowds of immigrants from many lands
jostle against one another and against
the roaming pigs that were the only
effective collectors of garbage bathing
was little practiced even clean drinking
water was a luxury beyond the reach of
the indigent the street people who
milled around outside the relative
elegance of the State House in
Philadelphia were strangers to one
another their languages culture dress
and deportment certainly did not evoke a
sense of shared nationality but
apparently they did share was
drunkenness drunkenness led easily and
quickly to violent
and was anticipated at every hand
gentlemen war swords sometimes hidden in
canes and often carried pistols there
was little civil authority every man was
on his own recognizing the failures of
their attempt to create stable governing
institutions the Confederation Congress
had authorized the holding of a
convention to amend the Constitution
amending the Articles of Confederation
was the official mandate of the
Philadelphia Convention but the
delegates took their authority beyond
what had been licensed they planned not
to amend but to replace the existing
government put baldly
what they were doing a matter - a coup
d'etat and for that reason they
determined to hold their discussions in
secrecy not surprisingly one of the
first points on which the delegates
agreed was to sacrifice such little
comfort as they could get from the open
windows by covering them with wands and
by demanding that would what took place
inside the Hall of the Statehouse not be
revealed to the street they realized
that they had to be careful to avoid
what delegate pierce butler of South
Carolina called and with good reason
licentious publications so the delegates
sweltered together while they conspired
today it has become fashionable to
criticize them but the delegates really
were an extraordinary group many had
fought in the revolution General
Washington was unanimously elected their
president that is of the convention
Colonel Alexander Hamilton was one of
the most influential of the delegates
and as a group
delegates shared generations of
tradition and years of experience even
under British rule and running the
governments of their colonies they were
sure themselves as their conversations
demonstrated their extraordinarily well
read and their linguistic ability
particularly in Greek and Latin would
have put to shame many of today's
university faculties of course I exclude
Yale from
my comrade adapte they were nearly all
members of the small Protestant male
white elite while they were determined
to create a republic they were not
sentimental at all about the people they
did not expect them new citizens to be
able nor did they wish to establish
justice domestic ensure domestic
tranquility provide for the common
defense promote the general welfare and
secure the blessings of liberty with the
help of the people they hope to do that
themselves and they assumed that they
America's most distinguished and highest
standing citizens as delegate and later
President James Madison described them
could create a framework in which these
lofty aims had a chance of being
achieved that framework was the
Constitution they were driven together
by their shared perception that the
Articles of Confederation simply had not
worked the Confederation that emerged
was to hold the colonies together and to
provide for domestic tranquillity they
saw it it couldn't do it that it was
weak intentionally weak was
understandable perhaps inevitable
because I've after all the Revolution
had been undertaken to break loose from
an authoritarian government the British
monarchy and in no time certainly not
they knew how to balance Authority with
freedom they were not alone in thinking
worrying might be a better word as they
did settlement after settlement town
after town expressed its frustration and
anger to state governments and various
conventions delegations and individuals
denounced the very idea that sovereignty
could be delegated to any official body
contemporary Americans were natural
anarchists people power was the sense of
politics throughout the land and the
context of this mood law and order was
collapsing and even while the
Continental Congress was still in
existence it could not protect either
their particular interests or their
common interest members of the elite
were so disturbed of the
malaise that they delved into the
history of the ancient Roman Republic
and contemporary European states
particularly England to see how other
people had handled the definition and
practice of government the less widely
read public the general public was not
so philosophical or abstract as the
aristocracy but they too were fearful
and often angry the attitudes of both
groups were largely predetermined by the
political economic and social system
that have evolved over the previous
century the essential feature of that
system was the division of the land into
thirteen nearly self-governing colonies
each had its own customs of government
its own system of electing people its
separate attitudes or separate interests
and each had come to think of itself as
a state
however the revolution had taught the
man who gathered in Philadelphia that
separately they could not defend
themselves thus by their experience in
the war of the revolution that were
concerned about the danger of foreign
invasion but by reading and reflecting
they were deeply worried also about the
cost that would have been required to
prevent attacks against themselves in
their property that's a critical point
that I want to emphasize and the rest of
what I have to say the the sense of the
overhanging danger of doing too much to
try to protect oneself it was in the
context of their aspirations and fears
that they deliberated on forming a new
system how remarkable that that
deliberation was we could see by
comparing it or comparing what they were
doing with what's been happening or
usually not happening in the elsewhere
in our own times over much of Asia and
Africa and the aftermath of
decolonization successor local elites
continue to tear apart their emerging
societies and even the physical
inheritance of the colonial period the
founding fathers were determined not to
let this happen being relatively
isolated even from
contact with one another many had not
met before they gathered in Philadelphia
and contact among them was sporadic and
expensive the only real contact they had
was by post and a gossip driven press
but the press in those days were really
just sheets that had been run off run
off by our local printers telling what
the local gossip was I have to break in
here and tell you an anecdote about my
own family
when James K Polk was elected to be our
11th president he had not met the vice
president and of when they first met the
vice president called on him in the
White House which was supposed to be
turned into a warehouse because it was
in such bad shape the Vice President
came in and they talked for a few
minutes and when he left
James K wrote in his diary seems like a
nice fellow
so being relatively isolated from one
another they spent much of their time
gossiping together they also realize in
a reading that it was not just the
destruction pillage and casualties of
actual war that was a danger rather it
was the fear of these terrible costs
that constituted the gravest danger to
freedom and the ability to enjoy the
good life which was their principal aim
that it seems to me is the theme it
carries over into so much of what we
experienced today the fear of things
that have not yet happened but which we
expect might happen what we know of
their deliberations mainly in the
account written by James Madison are
filled with references to the
experiences of Greek Greece Rome and
contemporary Europe to the deliberations
of the great European who were then
recent philosophers and legal
commentators since we also know that
they shared long evenings over
well-lubricated long and heavy meals we
can imagine their months together must
have constituted a sort of running sum
are on governance and on the the
propensity of government to become
tyranny which is a theme that runs
through all of their conversations we
have to ask where the delegates got
their ideas put in terms of the analogy
I drew of the document they were
developing to a tree we could see the
seedlings that they were trying to apply
it the first answer is that they read
widely and surprisingly deeply they
virtually memorized Montesquieu's the
spirit of the laws and imbibed Sir
William buck stones commentaries of an
English common law which they assumed to
be fundamental to all democratic or not
democratic or republican governments
many also read emmerich sativa tells the
law of nations Benjamin Franklin bought
several copies and distributed them
among his colleagues commenting that the
circumstance of a rising state make it
necessary frequently to consult the law
of nations the second answer to what
they were doing is perhaps even more
compelling the delegates been through a
remarkable series of personal
experiences first the years of agitation
leading up to the revolution which were
followed by the often bitter struggle
with the British rulers they learned
about armies firsthand the party Merson
partly mercenary British army had to
live off the land and stole what it
needed
it was often compelled to fight a
guerrilla war in this insurgency that
civilians suffered but to different
degrees in different times by modern
standards the suffering of the civilian
population was relatively mild but it
deeply divided the population and caused
the expulsion or flight of many
loyalists finally the revolutionaries
and the many who just stood aside came
to feel a gnawing sense that may have
been that all of it may have been for
naught and these experiences were
compacted in a very few and very recent
years we must remember that in May 1787
when the delegates met
Philadelphia the memories of British
rule were very recent the Treaty of
Paris that ended the war with Great
Britain was son only in 1783 so the
delegates that the Constitution
convention met in little more than three
years after they had achieved some
degree of Independence
their overriding memory was almost
certainly of military action thus while
some of the delegates notably Alexander
Hamilton greatly admired the monarchy as
an institution the monarchs had been
painfully and proximately represented by
the British army to the colonists the
government to be most feared was the one
that had an army understandably the very
idea of a standing army was anathema
founding father James Madison probably
spoke for most Americans and certainly
for those who wrote the Constitution
when he said a standing military force
with an overgrown executive will not
long be safe companions to Liberty the
means of defense against foreign danger
have always been the instruments of
tyranny at home among the Romans it was
a standing maxim to excite a war
whenever a revolt was apprehended
throughout all of Europe the armies kept
up that in the pretext of defending one
another have enslaved the people so how
could a republic cope with this danger
the great conservative Alexander
Hamilton argue that Americans could
should copy the British system by giving
the president who was of course the
American version of the king lifetime
tenure his argument was that only if the
king felt safe would he retain from
subversion of the government that is if
he felt endangered he would use his
power and I quote to to prolong his
powers in the case of war he would avail
himself of the emergency to evade or
accuse a degradation from his place in
short war perhaps stimulated by the fear
of a would-be despot could destroy the
Republican render
an operative the system the founding
fathers were endeavouring to put into
place the other delegates were not
willing to go quite as far as Hamilton
they thought it was both possible and
wise to trim the claws then he would be
desperate for mothers cue spirit of the
laws the writers of the Constitution
concluded they must keep the armed
forces within strict bounds so few as
they required to defend the land should
not be foreign or a mercenary force it
should owe the Republic if it were a
mercenary or foreign force no loyalty
and even native troops should be at the
command of a civilian government which
would have the right to disband them as
soon as it pleased moreover while
serving under these arms the soldiers
should live in common with the rest of
the people and no separate camps
barracks or fortresses should be
suffered but modest coup continued
unless their carefully controlled armies
developed their own will it is natural
for mankind to set a higher value upon
courage than timidity he said on
activity rather than prudence on
strength rather than counsel as soon he
argued as the public accepts their right
to represent the nation they will
convert a civil government into a
military government this he pointed out
was the fate of Rome and could be the
fate of all Republic's thus as James
Madison later wrote in Federalist Papers
number 41 I quote again
a wise nation was it does not rationally
preclude itself from any resource which
may become essential to his safety will
exert all its prudence and diminishing
both the necessity and the danger of
resorting to the creation of a standing
army which may be inauspicious to his
liberties listening to the delegates one
hears that they wanted to see the
political power and the people as
Madison put it in his Federalist 39 they
believe that government derives all of
those powers directly or and
or indirectly from the great body of the
people but as a man of many of
experience in running your own affairs
the delegates of Philadelphia distrusted
the people so the Constitution they were
devising also had the aim as governor
Morris of New York and Pennsylvania put
it to save the people from their own
most dangerous enemy themselves here is
how the delegates perceived the issue of
power make war they felt that they had
to address the issue of who or what
agency of government could take this
momentous step and Madison's notes we
can almost hear their voices I want you
to listen to some of them as I read them
out or imagine that you were listening
to them because I will read it directly
as quotes but I think the key thing that
I want to emphasize here is how
desperately worried they were of the
disequilibrium in the system they were
trying to create an overwhelming
military a weak central government the
inability of these forces to balance one
another and only in that balance do they
feel that we have a chance to live the
good life that we all wanted to leave
and also to maintain our freedom
I start with Friday August the 21st 1787
and as I say I will quote these various
things
mister Charles Pinckney of South
Carolina opposed the vesting of this
power to make war and the legislature
its proceedings he said were too slow it
would meet only once a year the House of
Representatives would be too normal too
numerous for the serious deliberation
the Senate he thought would be the best
depository be more acquainted with
foreign affairs and most capable of
proper resolutions mr. Pierce Butler
also South Carolina objected saying the
objections against the legislature law
and great part also against the Senate
he was for vesting the power in the
president who will have all the
requisite qualities and will not make
war when the nation won't support it mr.
pinky found us
location of power to be a great danger
well he favored a vigorous executive he
was afraid that executive powers in the
existing Congress might extend to peace
and war which would enable the executive
to become a monarchy of the worst kind
to wit an electing vote mr. Madison and
mr. Elbridge Gerry of Massachusetts
moved to insert the word declare
striking out the word make war from the
text leaving the executive only the
power to repeal sudden attacks mr. Roger
Sherman of Connecticut thought the
proposed wording stood very well the
executive should be able to repeal but
not to commence war make is better he
said than declare the letter narrowing
the power too much mr. Gary objecting
said that he never expected to hear in a
republic a motion to empower the
executive alone to declare war these are
points obviously a very great moment to
our current situation as I'll come
around to mr. Oliver Ellsworth also of
Connecticut said there is a material
difference in the cases of making war
and making peace it should be more easy
to get out of war than to get into the
war war is a simple and overt
declaration peace is attended with
intricate and secret negotiations mr.
George Mason of Virginia was against
giving the power of war to the president
because he was not safely to be trusted
with us or to the Senate because it was
not entitled to it he was for plugging
rather than facilitating war but he was
for facilitating peace he preferred
declare to make on the motion to insert
the word declare in place of make it was
agreed to and that's how the text of the
Constitution emerged on this very
critical point so one breeze an article
one section eight paragraphs one at
eleven the Constitution state
the Congress shall have the power to
declare war after the convention writing
in Federalist number four John Jay of
New York who was our first Chief Justice
court was probably a general attitude of
the public and certainly that of the
founding fathers when he warned that
monarchs will often make war when their
nations get nothing by it beware he went
on they will do this for purposes and
objects merely personal such as a thirst
for military glory revenge for personal
affront ambitious ambition private
compacts to aggrandize or support their
particular families it was not long
before Jays list could have been
expanded to the desire of candidates to
win elections by appearing to be
defenders of national honor or
protectors of national interest war or
the threat of war as several of our
presidents knew can be ridden like a
surf toward electoral victory for those
of you who were here the other day you
will remember that I quoted that great
proponent of peace and tranquillity in
the world the German Nazi leader Hermann
Goering say it was so so easy to lead
the people forward all you had to do is
to oppose the threat of foreign invasion
or of the weakness and latitude of the
of the government in later writings
James Madison focused more generally on
the division of powers and war making
saying that those who were to conduct a
war cannot in the nature of things be
proper or safe judges whether a war
ought to be commenced continued or
concluded they are barred from the
latter function by the great principle
of free government analogous to that
which separates the sword from the purse
or the power of executing for the power
of enacting laws so what the Founding
Fathers did was to limit the military in
all the ways they thought would work
they plan to balance their little army
and it's astonishing I think for those
of you who are not deeply familiar with
American
history to fund that the army at that
time was composed of a total of 718 men
the armed civilians in state militias of
course could be federalized but only to
execute the laws of the Union to
suppress insurrections or repel
invasions and that they set out in
article 1 section 8 paragraph 15 of the
Constitution but they did not think this
control system was sufficient so they
also specified that the Congress could
raise and support armies but no
appropriation of money shall last for a
longer term than two years and the
Congress not the president was to make
rules for the government and regulation
of the land and naval forces in addition
despite the argument put forward by
Alexander Hamilton for lifetime tenure
and office for the chief executive they
decided to limit his term in office to
four years and restrict his power over
the Armed Forces to only to executing
the orders of Congress has bribed in the
in article 2 section 2 paragraph 1 as
commander-in-chief he was to be what
today we call the chief operating
officer rather than a chief executive
officer he could order the army or
militia into action only when the
Congress declared war George Washington
had been president the Constitutional
Convention and who became president of
the New Republic affirmed this
interpretation in 1793 when he
proclaimed that quote the Constitution
vests the power of declaring war and
Congress there is no offensive
expedition of importance that can be
undertaken until they shall have
deliberated on the subject and
authorized such a measure as I have
remarked before many of these issues pop
up in our daily newspapers every day
before us and the issue of who has the
authority to undertake war or
particularly to make what we call today
a first strike is is clearly specified
and in the Constitution
I turn now to what happened to the
constitutional tree since it first took
root all of the issues of war were
perhaps the most clearly stated in
detailed of the injunction spelled out
in the Constitution the delegates were
aware of the disagreements might come
about so the third major division of the
Constitution they ordered in article 3
section 1 and section 2 the creation of
a Supreme Court in his first major
ruling 14 years after the Philadelphia
Convention the court affirmed a
straightforward reading of what the
delegates had written I quote the whole
powers of war being by the Constitution
of the United States vested in the
Congress the Congress alone may declare
war the reading of the Constitution was
unchallenged for the following most of
the following century but an external
element had been introduced in 1800 into
the issue of War Powers that would come
to haunt America and our times and the
speech made in 1800 before the Congress
the then Congressman John Marshall who
later became the Chief Justice the
Supreme Court coined a phrase to
describe the military or foreign affairs
powers of the presidency the phrase was
soul organ the what he argued was that
the president as the Constitution
clearly states shall take care of the
laws be faithfully executed as they
related to war the laws were motions
passed by Congress but Marshall wrote
that the whole powers of war began the
Constitution vested in Congress the
Congress alone may declare war that was
and remained the Orthodox interpretation
but as we shall see was stretched far
beyond what had originally been the
intent almost half a century later in
1848 that then congressman Abraham
Lincoln gave what apparently everyone
assumed to have been the intent of the
founders when he wrote in a private
letter the provisions of the
Constitution giving the war-making
powers to Congress was dictated
as I understand it by the following
reasons Kings had always been involved
and impoverishing their people and Wars
pretending generally if not always that
the good of the people was the objective
this our Constitutional Convention
understood to be the most oppressive of
all King later pressings and they
resolved to so friend the Constitution
that one no one man should hold the
power of bringing us oppression upon us
during the Civil War the roles of the
president the Congress were again tested
when ships were seized and had to be
judged and what came to be known as the
prize cases in ruling on them the
Supreme Court again affirmed that by the
Constitution Congress again has loaned
the power to declare national of Foreign
Wars and the president has no power to
initiate a declare a war either against
a foreign nation or a domestic state in
summary we've seen that up to roughly
three generations after writing the
Constitution no question arose about the
division of powers between the Congress
to declare war and the President to
execute the war as passed by Congress
indeed it was to be another seventy
years before this doctrine was
challenged challenged it has been in our
time a legal basis has been brought
forward to justify America's repeated
engagement in wars and violations of
human rights because of this because
this has been important if little known
or understood let me and has led to a
low back with such disturbing force in
our sense of security trust in one
another and way of life I want to
examine how it came about and why it was
a violation of the spirit of the
Constitution here on let's deal with the
way later Gerald Durst have grafted onto
the original tree of the Constitution
new branches greeting what our great old
philosopher Benjamin Franklin warned
against an imperial presidency the issue
has been defined by the phrase organ a
soul organ it is the president who is
the sole author and so
factor in actions particularly concerned
with Foreign Affairs are making war is
this a possible or legal interpretation
as I've said the phrase soul organ was
used in a speech John Marshall who was
then a congressman made before the
Congress and not on a ruler at the
Supreme Court it's been taken out of
context leaving aside the qualifying
understanding that Marshall implied that
the president was the sole organ in
affecting a law that is passed by the
legislature but President John Adams did
was to carry out a provision in the
treaty with Great Britain requiring the
delivery of a criminal an article six
the Constitution specified that the
treaty was the supreme law of the land
rather than acting on his own he
appeared to be carrying out a
constitutional order but these very
slight early precedence of action by
President Adams and also the speech by
John Marshall gave a pretext which was
jumped on to and in a Supreme Court
decision that was written up by Justice
George Sutherland George sutherland was
an immigrant English immigrant who made
it as his lifetime mission to argue that
the President must be given a free as
well as a strong hand during the First
World War like many other Americans
including President Wilson he was caught
up in war fever of lynch mobs and
massive incarnation Sutherlands reading
of the Constitution was set out in 1936
in a case known as United States versus
the Curtis Wright export corporation
briefly put the case arose because in
1932 Curtis Wright was selling machine
guns to Bolivia which was engaged in a
war with Paraguay the two states were
acting as proxies for shell and Standard
Oil both of which believed that the
province along the frontier between
Bolivia and Paraguay had large deposits
of oil attempting to keep the peace the
US government decided to stop the flow
of arms
thus President Roosevelt and I quote
again acting under and by virtue of the
authority conferred in me by the joint
resolution of Congress declaring an
embargo on the sale of arms obviously
Roosevelt was not acting on his own but
under congressional authority
curtiss-wright then violated the embargo
and continued to sell arms and in
response the United States sued and the
case came before the Supreme Court and
gave the court a chance to rule on the
extent of presidential and congressional
powers justice Southern wrote for the
court and his opinion quoted in term by
later decisions provided the basis for
the assertion of presidential power in
our time for the war on terror he argued
that in time of war all restraints and
American traditional rights and
liberties lapsed further he believed
that civil liberties existed only in
domestic law well there was no reason to
believe that he would have approved of
torture the decision he wrote for the
Supreme Court has been used to justify
it and other practices in the war on
terror has also been used to give the
president a license to invade other
countries or to make as I mentioned
first strikes against other countries so
it has been one of the most important
decisions in the modern Supreme Court
and deeply affects all of our lives
essentially what justice Sutherland
argued was that presidential power was
far greater than it ever had ever before
been claimed that in international
relations the president is the sole
organ of the federal government and that
the unbroken legislative practice from
the inception almost throughout the
national government must often Accord to
him the president a degree of discretion
in freedom which would not be admissible
where domestic affairs alone involved
and that the restrictive provisions of
the Constitution were operative only in
domestic law and limited even in them as
a historian I found fundamental and
indeed
qualifying faults in his opinions and
therefore in the youth mated them to
justify some of the worst abuses of our
time they deserve
indeed demand our attention the first
fault is that American presidents from
Jefferson through Lincoln to Roosevelt
did not assert the powers southern on
assigned to them as I pointed out each
was careful to justify his actions as
Roosevelt did in embargo of arms in
South America by authority granted by
Congress Congress was to decide policy
and the executive was to implement it
not more not less on this point
Sutherland was simply wrong
the second fault and southerners
argument was that a he set a steady
stream of presidential actions taken as
his sole discretion for a century and a
half goes a long way in the direction of
providing the presence of unassailable
realms for the constitutionality of the
practice of the President handing all
aspects of Foreign Affairs but the acts
he decided specifically were authorized
by Congress the only major exception was
Andrew Jackson's disregard of the
attempt of the Supreme Court to stop
what Associate Justice John storey
called the iniquity of oppressing the
Cherokee Indians and disregarding their
rights this was as you some of you will
remember a big part of my discussion the
other day I do not believe that any
serious legal scholar today would argue
the Jackson was acting constitutionally
the third fault is that southern based
his argument for residential
overlordship on the assertion that the
state severally never possessed
international powers and that one of the
revolution ended in seventeen in 1783
peace treaty the powers of extended
sovereignty passed from the crown of
Great Britain not to the colonies
severally but to the colonies in their
collective and corporate capacities the
United States of America but the states
never
those powers it is simply not true in
the 1783 Treaty of Paris that ended the
Revolutionary War it was specified that
it was made between Great Britain on the
one hand and on the other hand
individually with each of the named 13
free sovereign and independent states
that's a quote from the from the treaty
indeed at the time when sovereignty was
passed to the States they had no single
chief executive and no single
legislature well the Continental
Congress was mentioned in the treaty its
sole function was to earnestly recommend
to the states to restore properties
they'd confiscated from British subjects
Sutherlin was simply wrong fourth while
southern and thought that sovereignty as
a single attribute in America in those
years was a single attribute in America
in those years it in fact was not it was
diffused as is common in all
insurgencies what amounted to
sovereignty was dispersed in the year
before the best-known Philadelphia
Declaration of Independence nearly a
hundred Declaration of Independence were
proclaimed by self-governing local
groups as I've written elsewhere one of
these was by my great-great-grandfather
General Thomas Polk finally v
Sutherlands associate assertion that the
colonies had no international or foreign
affairs role is also historically
fallacious what after all was a
revolution but an assertion of authority
these would be what they come to regard
as a foreign power each colony said that
itself up as an independent entity North
Carolina establish their provincial
Congress in 1774 Massachusetts quickly
followed their work was carried forward
by the second provincial Congress of New
York in 1775 1776 Virginia's Declaration
of Rights called for the proper natural
and safe defense of a free state to be
upheld by some one armed forces and
other colonies all followed there's no
sign the colonies gave up their separate
sovereignty that they did not of course
was the major reason
the Constitutional Convention being held
and during the Revolutionary War battles
were fought separately to the dismay of
General Washington the states employed
their own military forces under their
own own command rather than under his
later while the Continental Congress
enrolled an army that's old the
Continental line the states continued to
maintain their separate armies or
militias surely each of the colonies or
as they proclaimed this house to be
States was engaged in foreign affairs
Foreign Affairs the struggle against
Great Britain was the essence of
politics and each state as the American
historian Gordon wood has written one on
17 on July 4 1776 America declared
independence the colonists were faced
with a formidable task of creating new
Republican governments and plural their
immediate focus was not on any central
authority but other individual state
governments Sutherlands mistakes have
had profound effects on our lives they
were cited to overturn the careful
balancing of powers the founding fathers
spelled out in the Constitution for that
we've already paid a heavy price justice
Sutherland wanted America to have a
chief executive like Alexander had
sought but as fellow delegates had
refused an elected King who was
virtually an overwhelming power indeed
Sutherland went further than Hamilton
his King was to have such power not only
in foreign affairs but also in domestic
affairs more recent presidents have felt
themselves justified indeed sometimes
often impelled to assume ever-increasing
powers both because they tend to see
international relations is taking place
among a world in a state of nature the
either in actual or potential war
against everyone against everyone
but because the pace of events has
speeded up in an age of missiles and
rapid response in such a world a school
of military strategists has picked up
Sutherlands attendant to justify that
America be Swift
and using the sword as the eminent
scholar of American
constitutional law Louis Fischer of the
Library of Congress has pointed out this
doctrine was sited in 1950 to justify
President Truman sending troops to Korea
in 1966 to justify President Johnson's
introduction to Vietnam 1994 to justify
President Clinton's terrorism
legislation
more recently it formed the basis for
the memorandum written by John Cu then
Deputy Assistant Attorney General that
specific specifically justified the
action the president was a sole organ to
use military force abroad essentially
the memorandum certified President
George Bush's legal authority to invade
other countries as he did two years
later based as they were on a decision
by the Supreme Court which although I've
argued was fatally flawed was still
standing youth position had a legal
basis and the memos were eagerly
received by President Bush who began
preparation for the disastrous military
adventures in Iraq and Afghanistan in
the attempt to rein in the abuse of the
constitutional guards against excessive
presidential powers and specifically the
danger of imperial presidents plunging
the country into war came the War Powers
Resolution
President Nixon regarded it rightly as
an attack on his powers it was passed
over his veto on November the 7th 1973
it aimed to assure that the collective
judgment of both the Congress and the
president will apply in the introduction
of American armed forces into
hostilities and the president's powers
as commander-in-chief are exercised only
in pursuit of a declaration of war
specific statutory authorization from
Congress or a national emergency created
by an attack upon the United States 28
years later in the panicked wake of the
terrorist attack on the World Trade
Center and the Pentagon Congress rushed
another public law 107 - 40 authorizing
President George Bailey
push to use all necessary and
appropriate force against those nations
organization or persons he determines
planned authorized committed or aided
terrorist attacks against the United
States
then on October of the following year
Congress passed public law 1 over 7 -
243 authorized I give you these things
just to show you that I'm not making
this up as I come along paragraph by
paragraph authorizing the President to
use force to invade Iraq and did not
require that Iraq be found guilty of the
attacks on the United States this cuts
to the issue of whether Iraq had indeed
any possible possibility of attacking
the United States I was in and out of
Iraq a great deal during that time and
that was their government a number of
times they were absolutely convinced
that the United States was determined to
attack them with there was nothing they
could do and at the 11th hour just
before the American invasion I've met
with the Deputy Prime Minister and we
worked out a plan that would have
allowed the principal issue that was
then being discussed over flights by UN
aircraft not only to be allowed but to
be paid for by the Iraq government to
justify the fact that no no even thought
of any possible attack when the United
States can be made and of course they
were Iraq and any of it had no capacity
to attack the United States tens of
thousands of miles away and no equipment
to put any of his troops or equipment
there and certainly had no development
of nuclear weapons or any of the things
that we've been frightened of three
aspects of American actions are those
highlighted in the congressional
revolution resolution the first was that
American forces were to be brought to
bear not only on States but on
individuals and non-governmental groups
second the justification for action is
based on the UN Security Council
resolutions and third
solutions projected the creation of an
incoming interim government of Iraq that
is they projected for the first time
what we have now called regime change
which is one of the factors in our
overseas relationship the I think many
of us agree have caused so much trouble
in recent years these shifts in the
nature of the American constitutional
approach to presidential powers and the
issues of war have profound effects on
our lives today and I believe will
continue far into the future but to go
full circle i mr Turner in a few seconds
I have Lisan your attention their
decision was that the ultimate safeguard
against unnecessary war was the Congress
it alone could declare war they could
not have imagined the transformation of
that body as the economy the society and
the intellect of the American public
grew what happened was a series of more
or less unrelated actions the first
decision made roughly at the time of the
Supreme Court ruled on presidential
power allocated the airwaves to new
corporations that was in the 1930s an
attempt to establish I'm sorry the
attempt led to the establishment of the
Federal Communications Commission the
FCC which was made to ensure that the
Airways be used for public purposes but
the essential result was that the
Airways became commodities that could be
sold by the minute to anyone who had the
money to buy them purchase was very
attractive for businesses but also for
politicians whereas the American
tradition literally put candidates on
stumps to rying small groups first radio
and then television gave them
potentially vast audiences but that
access came at a large and increasingly
enormous cost to get the money to buy
access to the public became the
essential task of the typical
congressman he could ask his
constituents for contributions but they
came in drips and drabs
members of the House of Representatives
spent an average of nearly one
five million dollars every two years
just to be elected successful
politicians learned that the quickest
easiest and surest method to get the
money to win elections was by leasing
themselves or selling themselves to
special interests my favorite American
philosopher and humorist Will Rogers
from Oklahoma a fellow cowboy of mine
put it bluntly but perhaps with a smile
on his face he said a fool and his money
is soon elected joking or not Will
Rogers was right in 2016 an average of
95% of the winners of both the House of
Representatives and the Congress were
those who spent the most prominent among
the donors of course were war related
industries so public interest groups and
commentators have four years sought ways
to rein in the corruption of the system
by the quest for money their efforts to
return something like to something like
the drafters of the Constitution had in
mind have received two monitors a major
setback the Supreme Court ruled in 2010
and citizens united case and 2013 and
McCutcheon vs. the Federal Election
Commission case essentially that there
are no limits on contributions since
corporations are to be considered people
and lobbying is a form of speech which
is protected by the First Amendment to
the Constitution that prohibits
curtailment of free speech so in my next
and final talk I will try to bring
together the experiences it set the
pattern of action and the legal
decisions that form the American
governmental system and put them into
perspective of the challenges America
now faced in the world affairs and
discuss how they've impacted on our
lives and been what has been the
reaction to them thank you very much
[Applause]
well thank you very much for another
incredibly rich and wide-ranging lecture
we do have a few minutes yes sir
really enforce my Supreme Court justice
can really suede away our system is
working I am scared
I am too yeah defense attorney thank you
very much for bringing this up
unfortunately it's even more chilling
than what you've been able to describe
here we also have using the same
argument of the sole organ that the
commander-in-chief has the authority now
we have determined under the hedges the
Obama lawsuit that they can even put US
citizens in the military detention
without due process outside the
Constitution it's far worse than even
what you've been able to scribe to this
brief time what I want to ask you was
have a very narrow tunnel vision to
probably see the world and you
experienced that with the Cuban Missile
Crisis lay beneath where the military
was willing to use nuclear weapons and
thankfully this period stopped them
would you want to go into that fifth of
how the military is not merit deference
they don't look at things in the broad
away and even Clausewitz understood that
you could discuss Todd I've got a plan
to talk about that in my talk day after
tomorrow particularly how close we came
to a coup d'etat other military
during shortly after the missile crisis
but I think you're dead right I want to
thank you though I have so seldom in my
life particularly in recent year has
been accused of not being quite
pessimistic enough I should tell you all
that Todd was the one of the defenders
of prisoners in Guantanamo appointed by
the court and is a an outstanding and
extremely well-informed
person on all the things that we're I'm
an amateur so maybe I could ask a
question what you said about the court
is is certainly compelling and the
Sutherland decision but if it does seem
to me this is just put out there for you
to comment on that Congress itself has
been complicit in transferring this
power to the president so I'm thinking
now IRA Katznelson
affair itself when he describes during
the Truman administration how Congress
voluntarily essentially transferred a
lot of not only budget making authority
of the national security state but
decision-making authority to the
executive branch and if you think about
the the Iraq invasion into in 2003 the
resolution that they passed that
empowered Bush to go to war was largely
it seemed to me at the time and
subsequently that they didn't want to be
held responsible for the war so
essentially they would they would be put
themselves in a position to say well
it's Bush's war we we empowered him to
make the decision and so you know
thinking that the the downside electoral
risk for the war going badly was much
more
worrisome to them and the upside
electoral benefit of the war going well
because Americans is sort of
conventional wisdom among people who
study American politics that there very
few electoral returns - to foreign
involvement so they're essentially
protecting themselves by transferring
this Authority while going through the
motions of demanding that the wolf house
resolution be observed but not really
caring when it isn't and so to what
extent really is is it Congress itself
complicit in this transfer of power of
the executive branch rather than the
court doing it behind Congress's back I
think you're exactly right
but if I may take a note of Todd's
comment
it's worse than you've suggested let me
read you a couple of statistics about
three years ago there was a study made
of the members of the Congress and it
indicated that of the 535 members 117
have directly or indirectly been
bankrupted and at least two businesses
seven have been arrested for fraud eight
have been arrested for shoplifting and
these crimes are in addition to such
things as writing bad checks reputations
that prevented them from getting credit
cards or been a prison for assault or
using or selling drugs as one humorous
put it they are truly a cross-section of
the American public
knowing themselves well they created
unknown to the public something that I
recently have only found out about a
secret fund that pays off their fines
and their out-of-court settlements so
that the charges brought against them
won't hit the public press that's public
money not private money that went into
this this fund the second thing that
you're absolutely right I think about is
that the Congress represents the public
and it's woeful ignorance about the
world I have left out of my talk
thinking it may have been too strong
medicine to go into what the polls
indicate about our knowledge of the
world oh that is we citizens there are
large numbers of college graduates who
don't know where Washington is there are
quite a few who something like 30
percent couldn't tell what century the
American Revolution occurred during the
Iraq and Afghan war roughly a quarter of
the college-educated Americans didn't
know where other country was as the
people being a question before the
Senate to be appointed ambassadors in
various countries a large number of them
didn't know where the country they were
being appointed to was or what language
was spoken or what politics were
involved or anything else about the jobs
they were just about to take over and
the problem that we all face is one how
we can go back to something like the
dilemma posed by the people in the
Philadelphia conference if power is to
be given to the people can the people
carry the power can they do the job as
being represented by a congressman so
one section I've had to drop out because
of concert
because of time constraints it's what
we've tried to do particularly since
World War two to educate ourselves we've
made tremendous efforts in this field we
haven't spent a lot of money we spent a
lot more money on one submarine than we
spend on perhaps the whole program of
trying to create an educated public but
starting with Sumner Welles who in 1945
wrote a book called an intelligent
Americans guide to the peace there's
been a whole literary industry devoted
to educating the public about world
affairs
both your former dean of the law school
of Yale who became president versus
Chicago Robert Hutchins and the then
president of Harvard encouraged the
growth of general education that was an
enormous step forward then summer wells
also started a series of books called
the American foreign policy library with
our former bus sir Edwin Reischauer to
Japan writing the one on Japan the
foremost American scholar on China
writing the one on China and Little
Billy Pope from Fort Worth Texas writing
one on here but the result has been very
disappointing
we we still have these terrible problems
of ignorance and I don't know what we
have any real hope for doing very much
of anything about it I went out to give
a lecture one time it at a business
school in the University of Arizona that
was being paid for by a foundation on
which I was in a board member and I met
with a group of young people under the
during the course of our discussion I
asked questions such as how the Congress
operates various things how what what
was how the the Congress makes laws
what how the Wall Street business
activities relate to Congress what is
the the various or what are the various
government agencies that affect business
activities absolute C of blank faces not
one person had a clue about any of these
things and afterwards I was asked by the
Dean of the school
this was graduate school these are all
people all had regular college degrees
what I thought of the lecturer and I
told him I was quite stunned by this and
he said well after all we are a factory
we were turning out products for Wall
Street and if they don't we don't really
care whether they know anything about
what NATO is or what Europe is all about
or what our relationships with China
Japan amount to what was important is
their learning the toolkit that they
have to learn in order to be businessman
and if you look around in American
colleges today you can if you were a
young man go to say the University of
Oklahoma is one that I happen to know of
you never have to learn a thing about
art music literature history or anything
else you simply can go in and from the
first day that you are a college student
you can take your course on in quotes
business so I think our we have our work
cut out for us and if I may just end
this on one last note which is I'm
trying to talk about in the next point
where the dangers to our country lie
what can we do about them and that I
hope you will come in and help me do it
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]